blog mans numero 17 e per un numero
diciamo così importante ho pensato di
fare una puntata un pochino speciale
scendere a napoli andare a visitare un
mio amico che ha aperto recentemente uno
studio di chirurgia estetica ogni
medicina estetica
va beh non mi ricordo con meglio
chiederò lui che cosa che fa esattamente
e provare non lo so oggi mi sa che hanno
puntato un pochino vediamo che succede
ok sono arrivato a napoli queste
testimonianze aspetta niente
ecco non è il mare anche però essere
mare di qualsiasi posto avrebbe dovuto
fare in queste due ore e mezza di
viaggio dei video però non li ho fatti
perché odio le persone che si riprendono
stando al telefono mentre si guida e
leggi un cartello un mac novaro novità
ed è un un messaggio che che appoggio
assolutamente comunque
un momento di entrare dentro e scoprire
come lo studio salvatore mi sto facendo
pipì sotto mamma ragazzi ma se i
fichissimi ma ragazzi ma stiamo
scherzando
ma veramente ma ma questa cosa esagerata
ma enorme ma infinito questo è perfetto
per essere casa mia proprio di light per
essere certi che ci pensi in italia
nessuno parla di medicina estetica e
tipo il grande tabù e la prima cosa che
viene in mente quando tu parli di
medicina estetica devono tutti quei casi
che veramente brutti bo il cane umano
quelle robe che si arriva veramente un
soffio d'aria prendono il decollo fece
per artistico che le sono degli statali
io oggi faccio la cavia umana
vai il como non accadrà cade kolkata mia
uscita di agazzi è sicuramente da
effettuare
fino a ora punta del naso che scegliere
un puntata sono andato in giugno anche
se dici a secondo ride si abbassa il
mondo intanto sono tutte cose insieme sì
se uno se uno non sa cosa fare
dovesse tornare ad una vita di stenti
eliminiamo un pochettino questi ci
prometti sotto gli occhi che cosa sono
in fibra mente a questo questa carne in
più questa cosa qui e realtà ne grasso
che sembra un po costante lato che sono
grasso si possono capire io sante la smi
parole destra bravo per dire xantelasmi
e perché per me il mio corpo non sa più
ovviamente il grave è che la mette sotto
la t a il carbon laser pilla un
bellissimo nome quindi il cuore e
dell'unità vai vai
ok cioè non l'avrei mai fatto con nessun
altro e quindi con il fatto che ti
conosco detto vabbè dai provini come fa
questa polemica un pochino che cosa
succede
ho paura di uscire qui con la faccia
dell'altro per il bene della scienza del
bene cerca di limare della scienza per
il bene della ricerca che ci ammazza
un altro passo
ho io
ciao
io mi sto rifacendo mi sento uno spiedo
[Musica]
questa roba qui prima era piena di
grasso e anche qui era piena piena pena
di grasso bello è perché il web è una
menzogna come sono graziosa leggero mi
sento mia madre e adesso cosa facciamo
un ping
prof
o carbone
ok
certo
con 50
non so cosa riprenderò perché da questo
momento non vedono più
ok vai sono pronto
giusto così
e piacevole che
e quasi invita discoteca non senti che
quasi sicuri che se tu arrivi da fuori
che fa freddo questa cosa ti riscalda lo
vorrebbero non vorrei fare i piedi
ci pensavo che sei riuscito non lo so
contro 3
è evidente non far vedere come si è
permesso ancora non lo so adesso
scopriremo qualcos'altro
sinceramente questo naso bene non ho
capito cosa interna ma veramente una
sono curioso sono curiosa che veramente
mettendo un highlighter cedetemi trucchi
rialzando perfetto sono a posto erano
all'effetto è questo io non so se si
ragazze si si nota pedica è più esatto
signorato adesso essere una faccia è più
tipo queste cose non le facciamo vedere
stato già molto rilievo se non spengono
le persone stavo per fare una cosa sia
prp previdente hanno preso il mio sangue
lo sta centrifugando in modo estrarre
solamente le piastrine che hanno un
potere tipo di vino da vampiro e metterà
tipo in testa per poter avere i capelli
di biancaneve visto che con l'inverno
tutti gli uomini sappiamo che si passa
da frodo a gollum livello di
capigliatura queste se volete queste ne
abbiamo finito le punture della testa
che vuol dire non hanno fatto male anche
perché abbiamo un assistente pazzesco
che mi faceva liberare la testa il vero
che porta bene tutto un gioco di cosa
che può fare adesso questo libera
concorso tutto vada in alto odena ma
anche nokia io ferito ma come data
sinistra quello che ho dolorosa perché è
collegato alla lato piacere
della parte razionale tornerò a casa più
giovane capace e devastato dopo che
stanno meglio chi la guarda sono stati
la mostra parlando no ce n'è un'altra
adesso la pennina dichiarati tutti
dolore si deciderà il diametro di
penetrazione nella pelle
ok con i millimetri 4 un'altra scelta e
poi sentiva la velocità
ti prego ti prego ti prego ti prego
fammi sentire un secondo solo al secondo
siamo sentiti prevenzione se non di più
ma non è cambiato nella mia non è
cambiata mai cambiato ma è come fare un
tatuaggio in testa si accettano rapunzel
a rumori o la gode già di mettermi a
dieta di andare in palestra
i nomi sono già mangiato insalate
salmone se si può pure magnati la
plastica questo per far capire la dieta
camminare la prossima settimana 24
sicuramente loro sono tornato a roma ed
è secondo me il momento di diventare
serio e tirare un pochino le le somme di
questa giornata e farò pure le
considerazioni allora sono molto stupito
del tipo di cose che sono state fatte
pensavo di tornare a casa con una faccia
della stata invece effettivamente la
pelle più liscia i cittadini vedi lì che
non so se avevano dato ma io avevo tipo
un altro paio di occhi di grasso che
guardavano la videocamera e che ma loro
sempre dato fastidio e per quanto
riguarda anche i capelli molti ragazzi
lo capiranno io ho sempre avuto un in
sicurezza cioè sono uno di quelli che
avete presente di pocket i conti oddio
perso un capello ed è come se avessi
verso un diamante è quindi per questa
cosa lo ringrazio né molto salvatore
perché effettivamente sono delle delle
piccole attenzioni che un pochino ti
fanno sentire che ti sta prendendo cura
di te e che niente di fanno stare meglio
sarò onesto lato naso
devo essere sincero e più bello il mio
naso ma non so se fra otto mesi lo
rifarei quando ritornerà normale ma non
per qualcosa perché il mio nonno mi
piace fondamentalmente gioia o un naso
che mi è sempre piaciuto credo che a
questa leggerezza si è anche importante
aggiungere un pensiero un pochino più
serio per le persone più giovani che che
mi seguono e che magari hanno delle
insicurezze stanno pensando di
modificare delle cose con la convinzione
che la loro vita dipenda dalle loro
labbra o dal loro naso o dal loro seno
io credo che il trucco la chirurgia la
medicina l'erboristeria qualsiasi cosa
possa fare possa aiutare effettivamente
ma non può fare miracoli
io credo che le ferite non si possano
guarire all'esterno per certe ferite
bisogna un pochino lavorare noi vedente
io dieci anni fa adesso 31 anni ma a 21
anni mi sentivo una merda cioè mi facevo
schifo
ricordo ancora che stavo con un ragazzo
che è automaticamente mi passò questo
senso di inadeguatezza ora non so non fu
colpa sua
però di base mi sentivo troppo grasso e
so che alcune persone potranno capire
uno di questo parlando
esistono delle dei meccanismi per cui
quando ci piace una persona quello che
quella verso una pensano automaticamente
diventa una legge quella persona pensa
che tu sei un fallito automaticamente
diventare un fallito se quella persona
ad ora gli occhi chiari automaticamente
il nostro avere gli occhi marroni
diventa un dramma perché facciamo schifo
allora oppure se quella persona pensa
che tu abbia le gambe troppo grosse
automaticamente ti senti uno schifo
perché dovresti avere due braccia al
posto delle gambe
questa sanzione delle due terza mi
spinse a 21 anni di nascosto la mia
famiglia a fare una ricostruzione che a
21 anni se ci ripenso di nascosto fece
una liposuzione per avere le gambe più
fine
che se potessi tornare indietro di
pigliare per la collottola riempire gli
schiaffi fino a farmi con fiale guance
così tanto da farmi dire ecco adesso se
proporzionato e dico questo perché
perché il motivo dietro una scelta di
questo tipo aveva delle radici più
profonde e delle radici sbagliate e
molto importante il motivo per cui
facciamo determinate cose è molto
importante ogni volta che noi facciamo
qualcosa chiederci perché la stiamo
facendo io naturalmente non posso darvi
consigli di parere tecnico per qualsiasi
cosa vi parere tecnico vi prego non
contattatemi contattate salvatore vi
lascio il link qua sotto per consigli
perché è una persona molto umana e
sicuramente sarà la prima capace di
dirvi sono cosa vale la pena farla
oppure no il mio invito in realtà che
siate dei fanatici della palestra che
siate dei fanatici del make up che siete
fanatici della chirurgia
io vi invito a non utilizzare tutte
queste cose per riempire dei vuoti con i
lidi dove colmare voi e colmate di con
le persone che vi vogliono bene e
colmate di volendovi bene e poi deve
sociale ha bisogno per fare qualsiasi
cosa che non
non giudico sono l'ultima persona che
può arrogarsi il diritto di giudicare
gli altri
spero che questo discorso che in realtà
richiederebbe molto più tempo possa
essere stato esaustivo ma mi sentivo di
doverlo fare specialmente alla luce di
una esperienza così diversa da quella
che che ho fatto in passato ma che allo
stesso tempo è stata piuttosto
illuminante io vi ringrazio per avermi
seguito in questo video e ringrazio
ancora salvatore per le risate per tutto
quanto io che dire
vi aspetto domani con un altro video
sempre alle 14 ciao